there is a regenerative revolution
that's happening in medicine right now
in precision medicine billionaires know
about it but the average person doesn't
what pushed me over the edge recently is
i had some experiences that really hit
me hard and the accident was so severe
that the prognosis was that my career
was over
what would you say is
available right now that people would
think is science fiction that that
doesn't exist but is actually happening
that people can do it's tactical right
now here's the coolest thing that's
coming now kevin
ladies and gentlemen believe nation back
for the third time on our channel mr
tony robbins welcome back man thank you
evan good to see you man i like your
studio it's gorgeous it uh it's it's
it's served me well it's gone through a
bunch of different phases but um yeah it
inspired one of the things i learned
from you is environment is critical so
this inspires me every day i walk into
the office that's really cool this is
our third time
we talked about money we've talked about
personal development those videos have
three million views on them
wow crazy the impact that it's having
and the reach that it's having but today
we're talking about health you've got a
new book here it is i'm holding it up we
got life force in our hands and this is
no joke man this is 700 pages this is a
serious book you can build muscle just
lifting it that's what i mean
why this book why is it so important to
you
well you know i think you know me well
enough my whole life has been obsessed
with how do you increase the quality of
life for people what are the tools the
strategies the breakthroughs that can
make that happen and there's only a few
areas of life that really matter it's
your body clearly because without energy
and vitality and strength you have
nothing there's an old adage that says
you know a person with health has a
million dreams a person without it as
one but then there's emotion there's
relationship there's finances right
there's you know your business or your
career or hopefully your mission and the
spiritual side of life and so i've
always focused on this but what pushed
me over the edge recently is i had some
experiences that really hit me hard and
one of them was being an idiot going
down
chasing a 22 year old professional
snowboarder
and i'm not a professional nor was i 22
and i discovered i couldn't do the
things this kid could do i found out the
hard way and the accident was so severe
that the prognosis was that my career
was over uh first i thought it broke my
neck it was just torn rotator cuffs but
when i went into four different doctors
the thing they came across one doctor
set me down and said as bad as this is
and it was you know nine nine because
it's nerve pain
he goes you got a much bigger problem he
says life as you know it is over this is
literally the guy's bedside matter i
said clearly you didn't go to my
communications center all right
and i try to laugh about it he goes i'm
this is not a laughing matter he showed
me my spine and of course i've been in
pain for more than 14 years and he said
look he said you have extreme spinal
stenosis
you know your life as you know it's over
there's no snowboarding there's no
running there's no jumping and you know
what my events are like it's you know i
got people 15 000 people in a stadium
for 12 hours a day three or four days in
a row people wouldn't sit for a
three-hour movie you can't do it by just
talking and so sure enough i you know i
i took the gut hit and then i got my
head together and then i called peter
diamandis who's you know he's an md from
harvard but he's also a rocket scientist
a good friend of mine and because i
asked these doctors well what about you
know what's the prognosis they said well
you know you may not be able to lift
your shoulder arm above your shoulder um
you know they may tear again
and four to six months of rehab and i
said you know i can't be one armed guy
on stage with my schedule it's just not
possible and so i said what about stem
cells and you know i i think you know i
coach some of the greatest of all time
athletes in a variety of sports and you
know like for example cristiano ronaldo
he was supposed to be out three months
he got stem cells and he was done in two
and a half weeks he's back back playing
so no no no they're not going to do it
not for something this severe
so peter says you need to talk to dr bob
harar he was also a co-author of my book
now and bob is a neurosurgeon but he's
one of the 38 years ago helped to
discover stem cells and he said to me
tony look at your stage of life i was 53
at the time he said you know your stem
cells have dropped off the cliff and he
said so going in your own stem cells
might work for an elbow or a wrist but
not the complexity of what you have you
need four day old stem cells and i said
i don't want field tissue it goes no no
not in a million years see when babies
are born we throw away most cases the
placenta and the cord now today a lot of
families take that and bob's the one who
taught that and created that whole
system
he said you need that because it's the
force of life and he said i'll tell you
where to go and he goes you can always
go back and do the surgery if it doesn't
work but i think you're going to find it
well i did three days of treatment 20
minutes a day is all an iv in a shot
but they were cord stem cells four day
old stem cells the first day i just felt
tired and slept the second day i had a
cytokine response i knew what it was so
it wasn't scary kind of shaking and
freezing for about 20 minutes
just meant my body really responded i
went to sleep and evan you wouldn't
believe it i woke up the next day now is
my shoulder perfect and i've had the mri
and so forth since then no surgery no
recovery time
but for the first time in 14 years i
stood up with no pain in my spine
and so that made me an evangelist i want
to know everything about stem cells and
then i discovered it's not just stem
cells there is a regenerative revolution
that's happening in medicine right now
in precision medicine that very few
people know about because we live in the
coveted world where everybody's afraid
and you know billionaires know about it
but the average person doesn't so just
like i did with money where i
interviewed 50 of the smartest people in
the world ray dalio carl icahn warren
buffett etc and then simplified it i
gave you 150 nobel laureates scientists
and the best doctors in the world to
show you here are the little things you
can do right now that change your life
in various ways here's some of the
newest technology here's how you can
prevent it and if you have somebody in
your family who has a disease or a
challenge here's the newest things that
you can choose from as opposed to the
old approach of standard of care which
in some cases doesn't get great results
as many of us now so and i'm donating
100 of the money just like my last three
books this one 20 million meals are
going to feeding america i'm up to 850
million meals when i first met you i was
setting that goal about seven years ago
so we're almost to a billion meals uh
and then the balance is going for
alzheimer's and heart disease and cancer
some of the top researchers in the world
how many times have you been told that
your career is over
well i was told i was going to die
because i had a tumor in my brain and my
pituitary i still have that tumor and i
that was when i was 32 and i'm 62. so
yes i've had a few of those but this one
was a little more scary i wouldn't say
it was more scary than the tumor
but uh you know it certainly seemed like
the pain was not going to go away and
being able to find an answer has changed
my life completely i remember the voice
box one where you know you said you're
never going to talk again you can't do
your thoughts anymore too that's right a
lot of the advice in the longevity field
is there's so much coming in the next 15
to 20 years that basically just don't
die like your advice your job number one
that was just don't die because so many
amazing things are coming
yes
what would you say is
available right now that people would
think is science fiction that that
doesn't exist but is actually happening
that people can do it's tactical right
now if you got a disease or a challenge
there are some miraculous things there's
a
right now and it's covered by insurance
and it's in 100 hospitals incisionless
brain surgery you go why would i want
that well if you have a mother or a
father grandfather grandfather who's got
parkinson's you know i wouldn't watch
this uh person who couldn't walk across
the room 15 medications you know people
understand shaking they can't hold a
glass they can't do anything they
literally go in with this extreme
ultrasound it takes about an hour to
find the location that's controlling the
tremor they treated in 15 seconds as an
outpatient experience again 100
hospitals covered by insurance
this woman got off the table
and walked across the room perfectly and
her glass of water hadn't fully gently
measured him when she reached out her
hand was solid she drank the water i
don't know if you ever seen anybody's
got those audio implants and then they
hear for the first time they start
crying your eyes out same reaction and
that was two years ago the first time i
saw that i've been working this project
for three years two months ago maybe
three months ago now she was on a 50
mile bike ride
i mean just unbelievable there's a
company right now if people have
osteoarthritis and it's happening
younger and younger people unfortunately
today for a variety of reasons based on
inflammation the way we eat and so forth
but osteoarthritis i mean it's
unbelievably painful there's no real
great treatment it's mostly you know
trying to use painkillers well there's a
single injection this company is in
phase three trials so this is coming by
they believe the end of this year or
next year so your audience knows phase
one is safety in the fda phase two is
effectiveness or efficacy base three is
efficacy at scale and then you're going
to prove so they're in the final phase
soon they're going to prove the end of
this year beginning of spring single
injection
and it fires off something called the
wint wnt pathway which is everything
you're made of is stem cells but the
width pathway after you're born is what
directs it off send this many brain
cells that's the main hard cells they
have found the fountain of youth and the
ability to either upload it make it
stronger or download it with cancer
where you want things to slow down not
multiply so much
and they literally your body with one
shot
regrows all your tendons in 11 months
and it's from your initial genome so
it's like dolly the sheep was old you
got a brand new sheep you've got 16 year
old tenants even if you're 30 40 50 60
70 years old just mind-boggling then
there's the things that also
that you should know about that are
breakthroughs in prevention
because
for example cancer
growing up i had this fear of cancer
early on i was i thought it was going to
die young it was horrible and then i
helped somebody who's still alive today
she was 40 she's not 80. because it
wasn't me i geared up i read everything
i said look if someone has stage 4
cancer and they're supposed to die
thousands of people live let's figure
out what they do anyway she did it she's
alive today i write about it in the book
but it changed my mindset it changed my
psychology about things but today
the reason people die cancer is because
we find out too late
in other words uh the cancer society did
a study with a hundred thousand people
and found if you have stage three or
stage four cancer 80 chance you died i
prefer 20 chance i live and what do i do
but their point is much harder to turn
around which is true
if you do it stage one or two you
discover it there's an 80 to 99.9
percent chance that you're going to live
and so you want to catch it early well
the problem is we only have a few tests
for cancers you know mammograms for
women let's say you know testicle you've
done for your colon and so forth but
most people
where they die is that cancers that we
don't have tests for so one of the great
things in this book is i tell the
stories of the heroes of the book the
people have created these unbelievable
breakthroughs that'll blow your mind and
they went through 20 years ups and downs
and still made it through why because
they all almost everyone lost a husband
a wife a daughter or a son or someone
and it made them go i'm not settling for
the standard care i'm gonna honor my
child by doing this so there's a new
blood test that just came out in the
last six months it's called grail
it can find 50 different cancers
before you have any symptoms
now the power of that is unbelievable
that with an mri which will go across
the blood brain barrier and you know
what's going on in your body and it's
really inexpensive and the guy that did
it his wife of course died they found
out too late and went through two years
of this and so he just geared up and
found the answer but it's so powerful we
you know we have these sinners these
fountain life centers that i worked with
dr bill kaplan 12 hospitals he built and
owned and then he finally said i'm tired
of disease care i want to go into
precision medicine i want to go into
regenerative medicine and so he's
partnered with me of a bunch of centers
across the us and abu dhabi but he
called me and he says tony he said it's
it's you can't even believe this he said
you got to see this guy so we're talking
about this man who just came in his wife
was you know she knew that what we had
she was pushing him he's like i had my
physical i did my blood i did my you
know urinalysis i'm fine we gave him the
grail test bladder cancer
but the cool thing is it was the early
stage it was a 20 minute outpatient
procedure he's got no cancer i'll tell
you another one heart disease number one
killer right men and women
but the cutting edge to know what's
going on which most people don't even
get is the ct scan they only go usually
when they got pain or problems a ct scan
if you've ever seen one is extremely
hard to read they're looking for plaques
in your body that can kill you right
well there's two different types of
blacks calcified and soft plaques soft
flex can break off and be the
widow-maker right turn you a heart
attack kill you or give you a stroke
but calcified plaques are hard that
means you're actually healed so he said
tony you know there's a lot of the old
technology up until again a little less
than six months ago it's really hard to
tell and so a lot of surgeries happen
they don't even need to happen
there's this new technology it's called
ccta
and this technology uses ai and
digitally opens up all your arteries in
your body that they film through the ct
searches with like a missile inside and
shows where the calcium is whether it's
you know
soft or whether it's hardened and if
you're hard and you're fine but they can
predict a heart attack up to five years
in advance and tell you more importantly
what to do to avoid it so my partner
called me and you know he's bill as dr
bill they call him his the most
understated guy this you know a lot of
people are hypesters
when bill talks he talks real slow and
quiet we all lean in to listen tony
he said you know
i have to tell you it sounds exaggerated
but i think we've we've been exposed to
one of the greatest breakthroughs in
cardiology in the last 10 years like
what is it bill you know my tempo is
different right he goes well he told me
the whole story i said okay i'm in i'm
going to do this
so my father-in-law is with me and he
just turned 80.
he's a self-made man built his own
businesses very much like you right just
go get her make it happen but his
business was lumber he's a pretty strong
guy when you turn 80 people around you
start saying you should get your affairs
in order and do your will and stuff and
i could just see the last two or three
years is energy shrinking so i said dad
look you're here with me i'm gonna go do
this test it's here in florida it's not
far from here just pop on the plane it's
in western florida and i said let's come
with me i said we're both old enough
that we're gonna have some soft plaques
but we'll know where it is and they'll
show us what to do so he said okay i'm
in i take my father-in-law there he gets
the test he has no soft flex his entire
body guys clean as a whistle at 80 years
old but changing him when he knew he was
totally fine was unbelievable i was
better than i was five years ago i was
doing great but not as good as him
and so then we have this technique we've
done for some of the greatest athletes
in the world it's pretty extraordinary
where
when you have an injury i'm sure you
know connective tissue gets in there and
then lack of circulation and sometimes
nerves get trapped people go through big
surgeries well now the state of the art
is they scan you with ultrasound they
can see exactly what's going on so i
have this ankle been a problem for
about 15 16 years
you couldn't touch it even like a
massage it would shoot electricity at my
body because the nerves they see what
the problem is they put ammonia fluid in
and it opens up all the channels the
fluid movements up the oxygen goes up
and the nerve pops in place it took 15
minutes you can slap my side of my ankle
didn't feel anything it's perfect so i
said to dad he's there i said that you
know he's having what makes you feel old
is not being able to move right
aches and pains and he has huge hip
problems so i said as long as you're
here why don't you talk to these ducks
they scan and they find two locations he
needs simple treatment for it takes 30
minutes
and an hour later he's walking smoothly
silk for the first time in 15 years
right 20 years he's like
he gets on the plane with me this is one
of my favorite moments he crosses arms
like this and he goes you know tony
these people talk about living 110 120 i
don't know about that
you know what my heart's perfect my hips
perfect i could live another 20 years
you've only been married to my daughter
for 22 years that's like another
lifetime you know so there are tools not
just ray kurzweil is the person you're
pretty much coding who says take care of
yourself today so you make it to the
time where this new technology is here
well he wrote that about 10 years ago
and ray wrote the introduction of my
book by the way raise a dear friend
we're at the point where some of those
things are happening right now but over
the next three to seven years there are
going to be changes greater than have
happened in 200 years because as you
know technology you know doubles in its
power every 18 month halves in its cost
well we don't usually see that in
medicine but we're all code so i know
you know i'm sure you know about crispr
and gene editing i mean we're curing
disease and everything cured there's a
kid that was on america's got talent who
can now see for the first time because
of gene therapy so there are so many
extraordinary tools both to prevent
and there are so many tools to help you
increase and if you want to talk about
more of them i've talked too long we'll
talk about those as well oh those are
great i mean i think of money master the
game you took an industry that people
were afraid of finances and
we trusted the experts and what you did
with the book was demystified and
empower people to ask the right
questions and pick the right providers
and it feels like you're doing the same
thing now just with health we trust the
experts to guide us to the right path
but now you're kind of arming people
with the tools and the right questions
to ask so they can make better decisions
and have more accountability for their
own health is that a
very true and not all experts are equal
as you well know whether it's finance or
health and so what i want to do is bring
them the best of the best with the track
records there's nothing in here this
that's my opinion just like the
financial book everything is some of the
best people in the world you can judge
for yourself what you might want to do
so you mentioned the fountain life
centers uh i went to the website it
looked like you had one in toronto which
is my hometown at least it said
opening toronto yeah i think they're
just opening it so so i'm 41 as far as
we know i'm in great health uh you know
losing some hair maybe receding gum
lines a bit but uh apart from that you
know passing my physicals
if i'm walking into fountain lifestyle
number 41 male
what am i asking for what am i trying to
get
well you might want to do you know say i
want to do an advanced physical because
at 41 you're at a beautiful tipping
point you can continue to grow and
expand and if you make some mistakes or
just have things in your own dna you're
unaware of your own genetics that might
need to be dealt with so the best thing
is to have the knowledge it's like
ignorance is not
bliss ignorance is pain ignorance can be
problems so you can do that in about
three hours three and a half hours they
do a full body mri they do the grail
test they'll do your hormonal tests
because at 40 your hormones will start
to shift at some point between 40 and
50. and you don't want to wait till
there's a problem like i give an example
you had a guy come in
um i think he was 44 45
remember his exact age mid-40s and he's
36 pounds overweight clearly not you
he's you know lost his drive and you
know we said well if you looked at your
hormones something very simple right but
most people like women know about
hormones but they think of hormone
replacement therapy which is like
menopause well before you get to
replacement there's optimization in the
world we live and you can make tiny
changes and optimize your energy your
strength and levels most people don't
dream about where you feel 10 or 15
years younger so the guy comes in he
works out like crazy can't lose weight
listless all these problems have have
you done your hormones oh yeah i've done
more hormones well show us the test so
they sent us the test and you know he's
at 2 25 on his testosterone well most
doctors not going to say you need
replacement until you're like 175 but
most men need seven to 900 or slightly
higher to feel human to feel alive to
feel strong all we did was make a small
change not a giant injection of this of
testosterone and a guy lost 36 pounds in
less than 90 days more importantly he's
got his drive back it feels like he's 10
years younger so you want to just know
where you stand that would be number one
then there's what what do you do for
peak performance like we work with you
know we have a center for example in
pittsburgh we work with the entire
pittsburgh steelers team we don't just
do rehab we do optimization i'm sure
you've heard of david sinclair dr
sinclair you're familiar with him from
harvard right so he's one of the best
longevity experts on earth he's a good
friend he's on my board
and david is 53
chronologically he's 33 he's younger
than you and i
at the level of his organs and how a
system works you can measure it now how
do you do it he's utilized a few things
that reawaken your body so let me give
your audience a quick lesson i'm going
to give you three words you don't have
to memorize them they're in the book but
the concepts which you understand so we
all know i think by now most people know
your dna is not your destiny those 3.2
billion letters from your mom and 3.2
billion for your dad make up your genes
think of that as the plan
but how you turn out you can have the
same dna and show up different than
somebody else because what matters is
your epigenome epi means above so think
of the genome or your dna is like the
piano the piano player is the epigenome
it decides what which genes turn on or
off your epigenome is affected by diet
radiation exercise sleep
just about everything you can imagine
exposure to chemicals
so you want to take care of it well now
i'll give you the three technical words
but don't worry about the technical
there are seven master genes that dr
sinclair has discovered
that completely affect the quality of
your life and how you age and the
aliveness and strength you have
and those are called sirtuins if you
want to know it
these sirtuins have two completely
different tasks that work really well
into your late 30s maybe your early 40s
and then they drop off the cliff
what do they do number one they
determine which genes get turned on or
off by epigenome it's critical in terms
of your strength your vitality and or
your aging two they reduce inflammation
which as i'm sure you know is the basis
of most breakdown and disease but three
most importantly to me i value energy so
much the energy in your body i'm sure
you know comes from those mitochondria
in every cell you have this little
factory that makes it covet gets in and
steals from that that's why people have
that long-term fatigue for example well
in order for those to fire off you need
these serotonins to be doing their job
but they have a fuel source they need
you've probably heard of it's called nad
and there's never a d
well nad is a fuel source drops off the
cliff late 40s and by early 50s it's
down by at least 50 percent
well without the ned the seratoons can't
do the things i told you about but they
also have one other task that just has
to split its focus because it has less
fuel it also
these sirtuins go through your body and
clean up your dna
so as you get older as you get exposed
you accumulate exposure to radiation
chemicals etc and your dna starts to get
compromised so the situations go in and
actually heal it repair it
but now when you don't have enough fuel
for the sirtuin it's not enough nad now
they have to decide am i going to clean
up dna or am i going to give them enough
energy for the mitochondria and so right
when you need it most because the
accumulated challenges everything starts
to break down it's kind of like if you
had a mansion and you were lucky enough
to have this great staff they're young
in the beginning the mansion always
looks new things break down but they get
fixed immediately boom snap your fingers
seven billion liver cells are gone but
seven billion new ones come
but as they get older and they get aged
they get tired and then they you don't
have the raw materials your mansion
breaks down and that's aging so remember
these master genes that make all this
happen need this fuel source called nad
and nad needs a precursor to be absorbed
in the cells and created and it's the
last word i'll give you it's called nmn
many people have heard of it n is never
emma's in mother n
well
it's dropped off by 50
now your body starts to break down
slowly but surely or you don't feel the
same way you know you need tremendous
energy in the brain that's the largest
source of energy or demand on energy and
all sudden you feel a little foggy and
so forth so
good news is it sounds like a terrible
thing oh my god everything starts to
break down
you can supplement this natural element
in your body slight problem when i went
with david who went with a lab with him
we looked at six different brands
because i was looking which one i want
to do and some are cheap 35 bucks some
125 bucks but no rhyme or reason none of
them had any intent in it it was
advertised and promoted and selling for
it i was like i asked the lab check i
said are these people just cheats he
goes well some do tony most of stuff
comes from china but he said the real
problem is it breaks down within 30 to
45 days so by time somebody gets it they
may not be lying it was in it but it's
gone now and so i said well what's the
solution so david has his own version of
mmn but here's the coolest thing that's
coming now evan if you take an old mouse
when i say old mouse like a 70 year old
human would be a 20 month old mouse
and you put him on a treadmill the most
they can go without exhaustion is a
quarter of a kilometer
but if you give them uh and by the way
the young strong mouse can run four
times that much without exhaustion can
go a full kilometer well watch this they
give nmn for 14 days to a mouse
old mouse
and within 14 days they're running two
to three kilometers 200 to 300 percent
more than the strongest mouse you go oh
that's great tony do my studies always
go with humans the answer is no not
always so that was my first question so
david's in partnership with a group
called eden rock and they have for the
last two years been doing something
that's top secret but it just got
released it was in the daily mail and it
was released by a commander who was not
supposed to release it they've been
using a new form of nmn a new molecular
crate called mib-626
and this molecule does not break down
like traditional nmn in fact its
absorption level on traditional nmn the
most you get is 30 absorption
this one has 300 to 400 more in your
body
so it's way beyond what they give the
mouse to give you an idea they've been
giving it to the strongest men and women
in the world our special forces for two
years
so the commander got so excited even
though it's top secret he talked to
somebody in the press
it got reported in boston and then
picked up in the daily mail but they
still don't know most of it i can't tell
you i'm an investor in the company
because i want to first access
but i can't tell you things that aren't
revealed but i can tell you what they
said
what he said was what you saw in my
studies we saw in the strongest human
beings who have less room to grow or
improve he said their endurance levels
have exploded
more importantly their strength has
increased from the same level of
stimulus and most importantly their
cognitive capacity is shot through the
roof so now there's three different
medical studies one's on covid both long
term and short because as i told you it
steals the mitochondria and showing the
impact of this new component there's
sums on kidneys because kova's long-term
impact often affects this and then
there's the traditional ones that
they're doing so the fda is tracking
this with the military and they believe
they'll have approval in 18 to 24 months
because it's already gone through safety
and efficacy now it's called efficient
scale so it's not going to be a
nutraceutical it'd be something you go
to your doctor for and imagine you could
have a pill that would massively
increase the amount of energy in your
body at a mitochondrial level every cell
that means every organ is going to be
operating better the right genes turning
on and off inflammation coming down and
your dna being collected and cleaned up
like you're 15 or 18 or 21 years old so
those are some of the things that are
exciting so i show you right now and
what's coming not 10 years in the future
12 24 maximum 36 months out
so exciting it's so crazy
it's unbelievable
last question tony you've done so much
to help so many people for such a long
time
if people
were to think of you tonight in their
prayers
what would you have them pray for
well good health of course that's how i
can stick around but guidance you know
continue to guide me so i can serve as
many human beings as possible i'm
privileged to have this amazing life i'm
going to be 62 as i said i look at my
life i've got five kids and five
grandkids that i so love and i'm proud
of i got the most amazing wife and i
have the most amazing life where i've
been able to serve literally millions of
people because i was born at a time
where
i could get on a plane and go to you
know
15 countries in a year and do 125 cities
but now i have the technology like being
able to talk with you right now i built
the studio because when they shut down
the world and calling up 10 people i'm
used to 15 000. i did a seminar last
week for six straight days for 800 000
people in 195 countries so i just i want
to keep this health so i can be here for
all those i love and i want to be able
to continue to serve so i appreciate the
prayers i believe prayer has power i
love it well the man is tony robbins the
book is life force here's what it looks
like go pick it up we'll link it up in
the description below tony as always man
thank you so much thanks for having me
man blessings to you if you want to see
the last time i sat down with tony
robbins check the video right there next
to me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there the
quality of your life has nothing to do
with how much money you have on any
beautiful children you have how many
people love you
the quality of your life is where you
live emotionally this is the time to
retool it's a time for you to say
where's the world now where do i think
it's going